each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's a pleasure to introduce dead
Gregor Doug specializes in parallel
graph algorithms and there's an
interesting area where he works both at
the SDK API and software reusable
library development from a generic
programming standpoint and he's worked
on things like parallel boost graph
libraries and he's also released many of
these api's to the world and he also has
an eye for implementing parallel graph
algorithms that actually scale so today
Greg sorry Doug is going to be talking
about generic programming in the
parallel boost graph library okay all
right thank you for Mar so this is work
I'm at the open systems lab the director
of the open systems laboratory is Andrew
Lum stain and we have some students and
other postdocs that have worked with us
in the past and this talk here is going
to start with a very simple question of
does my clicker work it does so
sequential programming is really simple
right you write hello world econ
through some machine and you get
beautiful graphics out this is wonderful
sequential programming is easy now what
do we do in the parallel case while the
standard model is single program
multiple data right we take our program
replicate it across a couple machines
and I all work together and so people
have been looking for for years and what
I'm going to talk a little bit about
context of generic programming parallel
graph algorithms is do we have a goal of
saying well can we take our sequential
programs and make them parallel in one
way or is there something that is
naturally both parallel and sequential
where we can take one program and right
across many machines or run across one
machine efficiently and how do we attack
this problem and so the way we came at
this problem for parallel graph
algorithms is to use this paradigm of
generic programming so generic
programming I said it's a paradigm for
building software just like
object-oriented programming as a
paradigm for building software and so
we're going to discuss generic
programming what that actually is what
means and then move into the actual
world of graphs with boost graph library
which is a generic library sequential
and how we use the generic programming
approach to turn this library into this
library hopefully with the minimum of
effort and gain some understanding about
the link between parallel and sequential
programs in the process so the first
question they start with is well how do
we as humans actually handle complexity
it's a tough question when you have very
large systems of course you can't look
at the whole system comprehend it so
what do we do as humans will we break it
up we look at only smaller pieces and
then we work on individual pieces
separately get those pieces working and
then we abstract away those pieces turn
them into abstractions ignore all the
details that are lower level we don't
care about those anymore we just think
about the interfaces between those
pieces and then we compose all of these
separate pieces into a working program
right and now what software paradigms
actually do is they give us a way to
express these abstractions express the
ideas of all these pieces and then
combine them and the programming
paradigms that actually do work and gain
a lot of mindshare are those that do a
good job of building abstractions that
people understand and that work well
with the way people think so you can
actually look at programming languages
in the history programming language as a
progression of abstractions and we
abstract in different ways at different
times so structured programming was the
first real set of languages and the big
thing here is procedural abstractions
right you can have a little bit of code
that does something when you give it a
set of parameters it always works and
one to that code you don't need to look
at it again we also saw the beginnings
of type abstractions and abstract data
types I bundling different attributes
together into one sort of type that you
only work on through various procedures
object-oriented programming is very big
now and what that does is it actually
says okay we have this notion of an
object or a class of objects where we
have some data in the data type and
we put inside here functions that
operate on that data through some
abstract interface and we use
encapsulation to hide many of the
underlying details now the other thing
object-oriented programming datums gave
us polymorphism on the data types
themselves right this is virtual
functions overriding functions etc where
you can have a subclass of a class and
have different operations on the
subclass than on the class and you can
treat the class itself the base class
you can treat all the drive types as
that base class therefore getting
polymorphism what generic programming
does is it takes essentially another
shoot off of the structured programming
with some of the ideas of
object-oriented programming so here
we're going to focus on the polymorphism
itself we want polymorphic algorithms
they work on many different kinds of
data structures and we want polymorphic
data structures that work with other
data types to build new to his
structures now the key of generic
programming is that we want the
generousity we want the polymorphism but
we don't want to lose efficiency in the
process now this is somewhat of a
reaction to object-oriented programming
where we have polymorphism because it's
expensive virtual function calls become
expensive inhibit optimization they have
costs on the road so we want all the
polymorphism without the loss of
efficiency and we're going to come at
this from a different philosophical
angle by invoking Plato so what is
platonic idealism so what did plato say
well he said that all of reality all
this world that we live in it's just a
reflection of some kind of higher truth
in the world and he thought this higher
truth was also beauty and isn't there's
beauty in the abstraction and so he said
with all these concrete objects we see
all of these chairs and they're just
reflections of the abstraction or the
idea of a chair okay he always like to
use the tree right you can go outside
see many many different kinds of trees
in the world and some of them are real
trees as and they grow some of them are
stylized drawings of a tree we recognize
all of these as trees because they're
all just reflections of this Universal
abstraction of a tree
and we can throw in our mathematical
data structures of a tree to that fits
somehow with the scheme you take this
idea and now apply it to software right
so what are the abstractions that matter
well we have algorithmic abstractions so
what is a quick sort it's an algorithm
but the algorithm is just an idea right
it's an idea of how you can well sort
data using partitioning and recursive
steps so when you look at one of the
concrete implementations right where the
concrete reflections of the abstraction
of the idea of the quicksort will their
implementations pick a programming
language write it down for specific data
types that is the link between all the
concrete implementations and the idea
how do we present algorithms you look in
a text book and we represent the
abstraction sometimes there C or C++ or
Java code in there but more often if you
look at the good algorithms books it's
pseudocode right it's just trying to
convey the idea of a sort so what
generic programming is about is starting
these concrete implementations starting
with these things in the real world that
we actually use it run and then what we
try to do is move more toward the
abstract try to build algorithms that
are much more like that Platonic ideal
of the quicksort and this is an
iterative process start with
implementations and then you're going to
look at these implementations and say
well why are these specific
implementations too specific what would
make them get closer to the Platonic
ideal of the implementation and we see
that for instance we have a sort say we
have a sort on integers or rays of
integers well why is it just a sword on
integers that's placing a very strict
requirement that the user can only use
integers so we lift away this
requirement we say well we don't just
need integers all we need is a type for
which there's a less than operator so
you take that notion of a less than
operator bundle it into something we
call the concept which is a description
of an abstraction so we can say that
there are less than comparable types in
the world which are all the types of
less than operators and we can lift our
algorithms so we have a sort that works
on all
less than comparable types keep doing
this process and eventually what you're
going to end up with is a generic
algorithm which works over many many
different kinds of data types and data
structures and two important things is
first of all when you use this out where
that needs to somehow instantiate down
to the same efficient algorithm you
would have gotten had you written it for
a integer if you're using that abstract
sort with integers it better be as fast
as writing a sort with integers this or
object oriented programming didn't work
because they don't keep as careful track
of their their abstractions we can come
back to that a little bit later and
somehow in this algorithm we're getting
closer to the textbook algorithm
something that really describes the
higher truth it would be a player would
say of the algorithm itself it gives an
understanding of how the algorithm works
and just it's essential parts none of
the things that don't matter so now I
get to look a little bit of code and
start from very trivial algorithm sum up
the integers in an array and see how
this lifting process gets us to a more
generic algorithm so simple summation of
integers an array very simple going to
put it at our bottom is one of these
concrete algorithms and we can look at
another algorithm floating up summing up
all the the float values in it ray okay
that's another concrete algorithm and
what we want to do is we want to lift
from these two concrete instances up to
something that's more abstract more
generic we can do that we use the C++
template mechanism so now we're saying
here is well we can have any type T as
long as we have array of T's we can add
it so long as there's a plus operator
that adds 2 t's continuing on well what
if we have a sum operation that works on
linked list nodes right and here we have
doubles stored inside a linked list
we're summing these up well this is
another concrete algorithm down here
it's still the same basic notion of
summing up values but now the sequence
has changed the way you you look at your
data has changed therefore we need some
new notion some new concept
and in the standard template library C++
standard template library we have this
notion of iterators it's also many other
languages where you can walk through
your data structure without knowing the
underlying data structures form and so
using this we can write our summation
algorithm to work over any sequence
whether it be an array a list or
anything else and sum up all of the
values in there and we get this
algorithm that now generalizes all the
summation of an array summation of lists
and many other data structures that
we've never even heard of we can of
course go further here's a product
operation on a linked list of floats
it's the same essential idea as
summation right you're just doing
accumulation what the operation has
changed fair enough add it to our list
here and we can build yet another
generic algorithm that works on iterator
is doing some sort of accumulation over
all of them sagarika algorithm might
look like this in c++ or pseudo c++ the
idea is that it captures all of the
ideas of accumulation in one generic
algorithm and anytime you're going to
use this for a specific case like say we
want to go back and sum up the the
integers in an array once we plug in the
values the c++ compiler is going to go
through optimize this code and you'll
end up with something very like our
first example the sum of integers in
fact you should get exactly the same
code from a decent compiler that's the
abstraction without efficiency and
building a generic algorithm so that it
doesn't lose performance but covers a
wide variety of use cases now the actual
process of instantiation is as if call
them C++ we tend to refer to this as
specialization in the world of generic
programming and the idea is that any
time we do a specific use we generate
the most efficient code meaning we
generate the same code as if you didn't
have all these abstractions in here the
key is that specialization works by
looking at your abstractions and
breaking them down into nothing so it
eliminates all the abstractions you
can't do this with all kinds of
actions virtual function abstractions
for instance calls through function
pointers can be broken down with a lot
of static analysis that often isn't done
so it's not necessarily a good candidate
for an abstraction mechanism to use in
the world generic programming so a lot
of what we'll do in the world generic
programming is determine what
abstractions are actually safe to use
and the list varies from language to
language sometimes from compilers to
compiler C++ templates are generally
safe because it's just a substitution
operation virtual functions are almost
never safe so lifting and specialization
are kind of like two opposing forces in
the world generic programming and they
need to be essentially in balance for
these actual algorithms to work well for
generic algorithms generic libraries to
work well so as you lift to get to more
generic algorithms your specialization
needs to be able to go back exactly down
to the concrete algorithms you lifted
from so every time there's a path up
there needs to be a path down and you
get to the exact same place
one of the last bits on generic
programming itself is the notion of
algorithms specialization so it's often
the case that for specific data
structures you can implement an
algorithm better because you know
something about that data structure so
really simple case here is we want to
compute the circumference of a polygon
which is easy to take any given polygon
and just sum up the side lengths of all
the sides however if you have an
equilateral polygon and you know it's an
equilateral polygon well then you need
only do one multiplication to get the
answer for any equal any equilateral
polygon is a polygon so this algorithm
will work but it's linear time whereas
this is constant time and so what
algorithm specialization is in generic
programming is that you're allowed to
provide multiple variants of the same
algorithm and somehow your generic
programming system your compiler needs
to select the most specific one of these
to give you the best performance
possible now I get to move into graphs
so back to play doh well there's a lot
of kinds of graphs in the real world
from circuits to communication networks
and so on and all of these various kinds
of graphs can be seen as just some
simple abstraction of a graph and this
is where we started to build an actual
graph library to say okay we know all of
these exist so we need to do is build a
library that works purely in the graph
theoretic domain and within the graph
theoretic domain we just need to provide
some way that people can take their
problems easily map them back into graph
theory so that we can operate in graph
theory over a wide range of applications
so the library itself is called the
boost graph library there's a book here
it's somewhat dated that describes the
evolution design at the library itself
the most important things about the
library first of all it's one of the
biggest libraries developed of the
generic programming paradigm from start
to finish and all of the algorithms are
going to lift away requirements in a
couple different areas first of all we
don't care what the graph data structure
actually is that does not matter we can
work on graphs that are adjacency lists
or adjacency matrices we can work on
graphs that come from existing programs
just with a minor adaptation layer and
we can even work on graphs that don't
exist in memory you can generate graphs
on the fly and operate on these things
the algorithms don't care what the graph
data structure is all the cares of the
graph whatever the data structure is
behind it provides a certain simple
protocol that the algorithms can use so
we also don't care how we associate
properties or attributes with the
vertices and edges it doesn't matter
what the mapping is so long as when you
have your domain specific information
you can easily tell the library okay I
for when you deal with when you ask the
question what is the weight of a vertex
here's how you get your answer and we
also abstract away from many of the data
structures that are used in the
computation of the algorithm itself
which allows users to plug in their own
specialized data structures and if
effects slightly different algorithms in
some cases or just optimize the
performance of their algorithm itself
with this library we get this
architecture where the algorithms are
considered central and these are generic
graph algorithms and then you take your
graph data structures whatever they are
come from the library they don't have to
come from the library plug them in
through a set of graph concepts describe
the protocol of graphs and then you take
your vertex and edge properties these
are what tell you how the graph applies
to your domain right if you're doing a
road map then the edges might be roads
you know information about roads you can
plug these in through it's called the
property map concepts and once you've
plugged in your graph types and your
properties it'll create a new algorithm
that is specialized for your particular
domain and optimized for your very tip
your problem domain from the generic
graph algorithm that process of course
an automatic now we get to get to
parallelism so generic programming has
been very good at taking existing
algorithms and lifting them up to be
more generic with respect to the various
kinds of data
structures that are out there leads to
libraries that are much more flexible
because they can work with your data
structures not forcing you into using
their own data structures so the
question we asked can we apply the same
lifting process to abstract away all of
the assumptions that sequential
algorithms make and actually turn them
into parallel algorithms right we're
moving toward this initial question of
what can we unify the notions of
parallel and sequential algorithms into
something that's very abstract and can
be specialized down to sequential or
parallel algorithms maybe four different
parallel architectures and the idea from
the start was to see how far this notion
can take us and build the parallel graph
library directly out of the sequential
graph library mainly to reuse code but
also to see how far this dis notion
actually works and what kinds of
algorithms can be expressed this way and
what can't so we started with the
simplest graph algorithm that everyone
loves a breadth-first search and on the
Left we have the code all of the code
from the sequential graph library that
is a breadth-first search so the code
itself is relatively simple we have a
queue and we just push our vertex in the
queue iterate over the queue well it's
not empty look at all the outgoing edges
of the vertex on the top of the queue as
we discover new vertices push it into
the cube etc it's a simple algorithm
question is can we paralyze this and
subtract whether we paralyze this we
start to look at what kind of operations
could possibly be paralyzed or rather we
can look at all the operations in here
and see how would they act if this were
actually is a spin d parallel program so
if we had data distributed among
different processes and so we think of
on the right the abstraction of a graph
and maybe we have a data structure in
mind and we look at how this works in
the sequential case how do we enumerate
the out edges in a sequential case else
relatively simple we start at whatever
vertex we have and we walk through a
linked list the kids off the outgoing
edge
what if that graph were then chopped up
and distributed among different memory
spaces right what does that do to this
operation well if we have a vertex and
that vertex is local the operation is
the same we just look up the vertex and
walk through the list if that vertex is
not local if it resides on some other
process then we would have to send a
message and to a request of course
sending a message doing request that's
expensive so we can look at this two
different ways we can either say well we
need to have this infrastructure to pass
messages and ask about edge lists or we
can say well this operation here it's
the same as the sequential case so long
as we only walk the outer edges of local
vertices and so what this leads us to is
the notion of distributed graph and this
is another concept just like there's a
graph concept in the graph library and
the fundamental operation here is we
need to be able to enumerate the outer
edges of a given vertex and that vertex
needs to be local for us to do it so
we're lifting the requirements slightly
and that means that somewhere there's
going to be some kind of data structure
maybe it's a distributed adjacency list
it's going to distribute along the
vertices and keep off the outer edges
stored with those vertices so we can
iterate over them quickly from local
memory moving on what about the queue so
there's this queue where we push off we
push vertices into the queue check when
the queue is empty pop vertices off in
sequential case this queue is just a
first-in first-out q push at the end pop
from the front well we certainly don't
want to have just one queue in the in
the world of a distributed parallel
system we're going to need multiple
queues because multiple people are going
to be pushing and popping and so you can
imagine that we're going to distribute
this Q into several different queues all
of which work together as they
distributed queue and you can push into
this queue it'll move into one of the
other local queues and you can pop
top of your local q you can certainly
see the push operation invokes some kind
of communication here now looking at the
actual distributed Q itself there's only
three operations right there's pop and
top which we see we can do from our
local q there's push that can add
something into the back of the queue and
the most interesting one is empty
because this is what signals termination
in the sequential case when the queue is
empty we're done we have to look at this
from the distributed Q viewpoint say
well what does empty actually mean for a
given process well a queue is only empty
when its local queue is empty and
everyone else's local queues are empty
and there are no messages in tow so the
empty operation is really a
synchronization point between all the
processors to say well where is the
queues full overall state and what we
end up with is the notion of a
distributed queue or you have all these
separate local queues the push operation
is most important is the push operation
is going to decide I have a vertex to
push where does it go who gets that
vertex and the only answer we can
actually use here is that if people are
going to pull off their local queues
then when you're pushing on to a queue
it better pass it over to the processor
that owns that Q so this operation works
so we have some coordination between
data structures here we say that the
queue is going to make sure that the
appropriate processors get the right
vertices so that they can always
traverse their local vertices here
there's one last set of operations
inside the breadth first search which is
this notion of the color of a vertex so
we use white four vertices we've never
seen gray four vertices we've seen but
we haven't processed yet and black four
vertices that are already finished and
throughout the algorithm we're going to
query the color of target vertices when
we're doing the breadth first search and
based on that decide whether to push
into the queue or where they're not to
push into the queue in the world the bgl
you can imagine there's some virtual
table here that maps
vertices to the colors of those vertices
and in a world of distributed memory
computation for parallel computation
you're going to need to divide the
structure up into several different
structures now again we're going to use
a convention that if a processor owns a
vertex it's also going to own its color
so to keep all information locally and
these colors are in different memory
spaces we might have these ghost cells
here that describe that keep old copies
or potentially old copies of the colors
of vertices on other processors and we
tie this together with the distributed
property map operation the distributive
property map data structure and this is
actually a class of data structures
because it's a concept it's not a a real
type but there's only two operations
here we need to be able to set the value
of a protector edge or get the value of
a vertex or edge now both of these imply
communication a put operation to set the
value implies sending a message across
the wire and that person deciding well
how is he going to handle puts from
multiple processors at the same time
inside this disrupt distributive
property map notion we're going to have
these ghost cells automatically handled
and the get operation that retrieves a
valuable that may need to do in some
cases depending on the algorithm it may
need to go across the wire and ask for a
value it may be able to synthesize a
safe value locally so we've talked about
three main kinds of distributed data
structure concepts that are here we've
got property maps the distributed graphs
and distributed queues and all of those
are necessary to make that breadth first
search algorithm we had work like a
parallel algorithm so this is what the
actual declaration of breadth first
search looks like in the sequential
graph library it's parameterised on the
graph so it works with any graph data
structure it's parameterised the queue
so it works with any Q typically use the
first-in first-out cube but not always
it's parameterised on the color map
which is how we associate the colors
with the vertices and there's this other
parameter probably won't talk about much
that is a visitor that gives you events
each time something interesting
happens during the breadth-first search
that's used by users to customize the
algorithm as they go along so if you
want to parallel with Mathis sequential
algorithm we need to plug in all of
those distributed data structures that
we found from the from studying the
algorithm itself which means we need to
plug in a distributed graph instead of a
local sequential graph here we need to
plug in a distributed queue that knows
how to do pushes that send messages
across the wire and those how to
synchronize all of the queues and we
need a distributed color map that knows
how to send to do put operations across
all of the various all the various
processors and synchronize data access
to the properties of distributed graph
once we plug all of these into the
sequential algorithm we end up with a
parallel algorithm it's a somewhat
strange result as the sequential
implementation we have that's been
around for years and years is just
developed for data structure
independence also has a distributed
memory parallel algorithm in it you just
need to give it the right data
structures so so we decided on what the
parallel bgl architecture actually would
would be as a generic library we took
the bgl architecture itself and we found
that we could wrap all the parallel
component surround the sequential
components so we take the
high-performance sequential components
we have wrap another layer around it
that does communication across processes
and we get massive reuse of code for
instance the breadth-first search
algorithm does not change which is drop
in the right data structures and so our
parallel graph algorithms either are or
use directly all the sequential graph
algorithms we wrap those around and then
we take for instance are distributed
graph data structures all have the local
data structures built in and you can
plug those into our parallel graph
algorithms take our local properties
that have information about local
vertices and edges distribute them to
give the coordination across all the
various processors plug that into the
parallel algorithm and finally there's a
set of abstractions which we call the
process groups that abstract the notion
of communication of on all of your
process
and so we tend to use MPI the message
passing interface for a large-scale
distributed computation and but we can
also do threads or other systems that
know how to pass messages essentially
and we plug this communication
abstraction in throughout all the
distributed graph data structures the
discriminative property maps and the
description of the distributed
algorithms themselves to effect parallel
graph algorithms that are set up for a
particular environment and are optimized
for a particular environment so the
process groups themselves they actually
use a message passing style internally
with active messages that's the basic
model for computation and we divided up
most computations into bsp like super
steps BSP being the bulk synchronous
parallel model now the strict bulk
synchronous parallel model is a bad idea
because you can't keep your memory usage
to something usable however the notion
of super steps makes algorithm design
much much simpler and a lot of the graph
algorithms we've found have very natural
super step boundaries we can do
computation so one of the most important
things about the process group concepts
themselves is they have explicit support
for distributed data structures like to
distribute cues like the distributive
property maps because within any
particular algorithm in a parallel
algorithm you tend to have many many
different distributed data structures
sometimes the algorithm knows about
these sometimes it doesn't because the
user might have their own that they've
stuck in through a visitor so the
process groups actually tie together all
these distributes data structures so
they all synchronize together within
super step boundaries it actually gives
us a very simple model where the
parallel graph algorithms don't need to
know about all this extra work that's
going on well that's why sequential
algorithm was also parallel and it means
that users get a lot of flexibility and
using the pair of parallel graph
algorithms and customizing them for
their own usage scenarios
look a little bit more code if you're
actually using the library a lot of
these pieces are hidden from you so when
you want to go build something say you
want to build your road map and it looks
something like this what do you need to
do you need to have the abstract
structure of the graph and you need to
tell the library how that structure is
going to be laid out in memory what data
structures they should use etc it's all
your choice and then you add in your
domain specific information that say
well what is a vertex the vertex is a
city that maybe has a name and a
distance from some source and what is an
edge well maybe it's a highway with a
name and the length and miles of the
highway and then you build your graph
data type so you could create your own
data types if you'd like to create your
own data structures that's fine the
library also provides one it calls
adjacency list which is the Swiss Army
knife of graph data structures when
you're using the adjacency list you
essentially decide how it's going to
store things at every single level of
the hierarchy so the first parameter
here is when you have an vertex there's
a set of out edges how's that stored
we're telling the library use a linked
list for the storage that'll give us
fast insertion and removal and when we
moved to the vertices we say well how
are these vertices going to be stored
well the vertices are going to be
distributed across processors to
communicate among all of these
processors we're going to use MPI that's
a process group and each processor
locally is going to store these vertices
in a vector than amply sized array had
we left off distributed us an MPI
process group and just use that guess
well that would say store overseas and
vectors that would be a local graph this
is where the distribution enters and we
say well how our edges are they directed
edges are they directed edges with
backlinks in this case we're going to
use undirected edges so there's no
directedness to them at all it will be
stored in both places and then we add
our domain specific information saying
that with each vertex there is a city
and with each edge there is a highway
structure and these are going to be
stored along with the vertices wherever
they are and
in the actual program so the hardest
part of a lot of computations and graphs
is actually getting these graphs built
and distributed properly we've run into
this trouble with many different things
and the basic problem is that your graph
is much bigger than memory always and so
you need to distribute the graph on the
fly from usually many different input
sources and so one of the things the
parallel bgl tries to do well is
simplify this task and in fact we've
simplified it down to basically this
these lines of code where you have some
input stream and everyone has a
different interest rate presumably
pulling your data about edges from that
input stream and then add those edges to
your graph and what's happening behind
the scenes here there's actually a lot
of a lot of work going on there's a
mapping that you provide from the vertex
properties as in every vertex is the
city to some kind of unique identifier
for that name so for City it could be
the name and the name of that city
including its state information if we're
talking about a web graph that would be
a URL for a document whatever that
unique thing is and once you've
identified this the parallel bgl itself
is going to keep track of that mapping
in both directions so that you can talk
in terms of the name of this entity and
it will manage all of the distribution
behind the scenes by default it uses a
very foolish randomized distribution
strategy however for any serious
application you plug in your own
strategy for distribution that's based
on whatever istics are useful we know
some of their sticks for web graphs the
heuristics vary from domain to domain so
much that we have to leave this up to
the user
so once we built our roadmap which is
relatively simple say we want to run
some op operations on it we want to
compute the shortest paths from well
we're starting at Bloomington here out
to everyone else on the graph simple
shortest paths computation so first
thing to do is we want to find the
vertex descriptor associated with
Bloomington vertex descriptor is like
the internal name of a vertex inside the
graph library it's how we defer to
vertices and then the shortest paths
computation itself is relatively simple
it's going to be Dykstra based starting
from Bloomington and then we tell the
algorithm where it should store
information about the distances from the
source to these other locations and what
we say here is well there's a city
structure associated with every vertex
so store it in the distance member of
that city structure and how do we decide
what it actually means to traverse an
edge with the weight of an edges within
the Dijkstra's algorithm well we know
that every edge is a highway so we pull
out the length field of that Highway if
you want to do something differently
like finding the fastest path instead of
the shortest path we could just drop in
another kind of property map that takes
into account the speed limit and in
addition to the length of the highway be
relatively simple and at the end we
print the results now the most important
part of this code from all the last
three slides is that it's sequential and
it's parallel it doesn't matter which
the only part that doesn't work well in
parallel is this step because your
outputs going to get mangled when you
try to print to the consoles of all your
processes but the idea is that this
original typedef that we created here
says that this is a distributed graph
and because of that all of the
algorithms in the parallel bgl act as
parallel graph algorithms it uses the
parallel variants of them if it's a
variant or if it's like breadth-first
search and the sequential version is
also the parallel algorithm you'll get
the parallel algorithm out of it had we
changed this typedef to take away the
distributed s and make it a local graph
everything would work the same maybe you
sequential algorithms so we're really
trying to get to the point where you can
write an algorithm and it's either
parallel or sequential based on what
data types you plug into it so we've
implemented quite a few algorithms in
the parallel bgl yeah maybe not quite a
few a few and we found that some of them
work wonderfully like breadth-first
search where you can just drop it in
your parallel data structures and other
algorithms fall flat on their face and
you need to take a completely different
approach to parallelism some algorithms
that do work a lot of the single
shoulders single source shortest paths
algorithms work well because they're
based on breadth-first search some other
algorithms work well let's see well
pagerank does connecting opponents
almost does force-directed layout
interestingly enough does work other
algorithms that tend to be based on
depth first search which is inherently
not parallelizable those sequential
algorithms fall over we need to do
completely different implementations of
things like strongly connected
components and so on but we we have a
decent suite of algorithms we're always
trying to improve this and and study the
performance of these guys so I like to
drop back to this this issue i came to
at the beginning where i said object
oriented programming introduced
abstractions that are slow or that imply
that there is going to be poor
performance and there's this myth than
the mostly in the high performance
community computing community that says
that any kind of abstraction is going to
slow you down therefore you should write
the lowest level nastiest fortran code
you possibly can and we've been working
to try to change this myth or at least
see that it is truly a myth and one of
the things we did with the boost graph
library is a sequential library itself
is there's a bunch of sparse matrix
ordering routines written in this graph
library they're all very generic they
work on any of these structures etc and
so we compared them with some highly
tuned fortran code so you can find out
lib for sparse matrix ordering and
happened is well they ended up
performing on par with these
teams there one percent faster in some
cases were one percent faster in other
cases but the point is that the
performance curves of these are exactly
the same so it is possible even with a
very high level very abstract library
like the boost GraphLab the library that
works on a huge number of data types if
the C++ compiler can generate very
efficient code out of that and we've
seen this in a lot of other generic C++
libraries you've heard of blitz and Puma
and MTL for our things more in the the
linear algebra domain where they've
gotten fortran level performance out of
very generic libraries and these
libraries of course work with so many
other data types that they fit better
into existing programming systems now
there is a reality that there are many
high-level libraries that don't give you
fortran level performance well to give
you a thousand times Fortran performance
in the wrong direction and what happens
here is that if you use the wrong
abstractions you can get poor
performance right so we need to only use
the abstraction as the compiler can
eliminate we've got an interesting
lesson in this where we went out and
found one of the only other free
parallel graph libraries in the world
actually as far as I know there's only
two free parallel graph out libraries
one's ours and here's the other one is
called cgm graph and we looked at their
performance results and they were doing
connected components on relatively small
graphs and they gave a performance curve
that was this and we were able to
duplicate that and we ran ours and we
were like 17 to 30 times faster than
they were I still well I believe we
could be down here still but the point
is we tried to dig into this because
they were implementing essentially the
same algorithms it was C++ over MPI same
basic algorithms the same generally
basic approach in there based on
coarse-grained multi computer model or
BSP like at the time and we trying to
decide where does this performance
problem actually lie because it's
obviously not the lower layers it's in
the library and we found that they
weren't managing their
tractions properly they have virtual
function calls they have lots of heap
allocations that aren't necessary and
essentially what they've done is they
built a simple data structure as their
model and then they implemented their
algorithms using the object-oriented
polymorphism style and that lost them
the 30x performance this is the same
kind of performance problems we see when
we compare against Java libraries where
he had virtual function calls everywhere
in direct calls and we see 30 40 x speed
ups in that case now interestingly the
parallel BTL is a much more generic
library actually works across a larger
class graph algorithms than cgm graph
could so it's more abstract yet more
efficient at the same time now what we
don't know can't answer for you is
whether someone can go in and build
something on mpi that's down here
because we made a mistake in our
abstractions it could happen so just
looking really quickly a couple other
algorithms performance results here
there's now rhythm called delta stepping
for shortest paths and what it is it's a
single source shortest paths it's
roughly Dykstra like with a parallel
queue and we ran this on air to trainee
graphs on a relatively small cluster
it's about 100 nodes and performance
curves we're getting decent strong
scaling as we add more vertices and
scale the size of the problem we get
decent weak scaling as well so these are
graphs with billion vertices couple
billion edges we'd like to go much
larger for shortest paths but we haven't
gotten there yet we can look at it as a
slightly different metric as an how many
vertices per second can we actually
process on these on these graphs and
from here as we increase the size of the
graph we process slightly fewer vertices
per second because this is not actually
a linear algorithm but they were getting
decent performance across all different
graph sizes within our within our
cluster environment and this is just a
simple commodity cluster
it talks a lot about data abstraction
and how the parallel bgo works on
multiple data structures so this
actually matters to users because they
have trade-offs to make and what data
structures to use and we want them to
make those trade-offs not us will
support everything so here we're
actually doing something from the die
max shortest paths challenge where we're
doing shortest paths computations on the
USA roadmap and here we want to do the
exact same computation except switching
off between a compressed sparse
representation and the adjacency list
representation both are part of the
boost graph library and we see that with
compressed farce row we're getting about
things that run time is about half here
so we're getting a 2x speed up moving
from the adjacency list to the
compressed farce row of course the
compress sparse row graph is much much
more tightly packed into memory than
adjacency list so we can actually run on
many fewer processors so we're using
less memory but there's more trade-offs
than that so compressed farce row is
certainly faster you get better cash
locality put more into memory than
adjacency lists but an adjacency list is
much easier to use for the users so the
way we expect users to do things is well
they'll probably work in adjacency lists
if their applications running and then
if it's worth the performance hit and
the time spent they can convert from one
data structure to another most of the
program will remain exactly the same all
the algorithms will run will be the same
algorithms but we'll get this extra
performance from improved memory
locality just by changing the data
structures
very last bit here very good generic
libraries can be composed and by
composed I mean you can take two
different libraries independently
develops possibly even for different
domains and use them together in some
way to us them together into your
application domain so what we really
want to do this because when a library
is composable with other libraries it
means that you could now take ideas from
one domain and apply them directly in
another domain which may be your
application domain or it may may be
related through some third application
to the domain that you're interested in
and so we did a case study here in
parallel graph eigen solvers so the
eigenvectors of graphs provide
information about various depending
which eigenvectors you're looking at you
get information about different
characteristics of the graph for
instance connectivities one of them and
so there's this other library out in the
world called the iterative I Consalvo
template library so it's a free c++
library developed and at the University
of Zurich and it works in the world of
linear algebra and we said well we know
that a graph can be viewed as a matrix
right you can view a graph as its
adjacency matrix so can we compose the
parallel bgl which art existed at that
time with the I ETL developed by someone
else and actually compute the
eigenvectors of parallel graphs using
the I ETL without right rewriting any of
the algorithms the ideal or rewriting
our own data structures so both of these
are generic libraries and we're actually
able to develop a set of thin adaptors
as in there a couple hundred lines of
code that make the existing parallel bgl
graphs act like matrices like they could
be 01 matrices if you're just looking at
the structure of the graph or they could
be weighted matrices if you have edge
weights in there whichever you'd like
and this the idea is that we just write
the thin adapter layer where the few
core linear algebra like operations you
that the I etl needs to be able to do
its solving of
eigen vectors can be applied directly to
a parallel bjo graph so it's just it's
not a conversion of data structures it's
a view on a data structure from the
perspective of a different domain and we
took the parallel pgl property maps
which associate information with each of
the vertices or the edges in the graph
and when you're associating information
with each of those you can view this as
like another vector of information in a
linear algebra sense and what we get is
an architecture like this where we have
the PB GL on one side and it plugs into
a set of adapters here that map from the
world of graph theory I should parallel
graphs but it's just graph theory into
the world of linear algebra and through
these adapters which are very
lightweight entities like I said we can
plug those directly into the generic
algorithms of the I et al and what we
actually get is using a parallel library
here in a sequential library here we
plug this in and we affect a parallel
graph icon sulfur out of these two
libraries as couple scalability numbers
these aren't terribly interesting other
than they moved randomly in the correct
direction we'd like to do a lot more
studies in this area because there's a
lot of work that goes on in building
good libraries for very specific domains
but as soon as we have the ability to
plug libraries together for many
different domains we're going to get the
idea we're going to get much more cross
domain fertilization and with generic
libraries it becomes very easy to plug
one library into another and plug many
libraries together and we could have
another parallel graph library over here
as long as it meets the ideas and the
interfaces of the parallel boost graph
library it will automatically work
within the I ETL so you can do
essentially graph eigenvectors on a
third party library that knows nothing
about even generic programming
so try to wrap things up here generic
programming itself is technology for
building software libraries so there's
dual focus in generic programming first
of all the focus is on reusability we
want libraries that are flexible that
work with many different data types that
can be adapted easily to your program
instead of adapting your program to the
library and second of all we focus on
performance the abstractions that we put
into the library to get this reusability
to get this generosity cannot affect
performance otherwise the library's
going to be much less usable useful we
found that this is applicable to
paralyzing existing sequential
algorithms in some cases it isn't always
applicable so the parallel graph library
itself is a generic parallel graph
library generic with respect to the
graph data structures properties on the
graphs and the underlying communication
medium that's it's used to coordinate
different processors it just has a suite
of distributed memory parallel graph
algorithms haven't looked at shared very
much and it's efficient more efficient
than what we've seen we don't know what
the baseline is and scalable at least
out to the hundreds of processors that
we have available to us now who knows
when we go to much larger systems if
you're interested in the parallel bgo of
course you can talk to me there's a web
page out here with more information
publications etc are there any questions
so how does dynamic graphs more frankly
the whole party gown vertices yes looks
great when this when your graph is
static but if your graph is built on the
fly well if the graph is built on the
fly then the way that you add new
vertices or edges into the system you
need to know where they go so the way
that we do our distribution is not
through a static distribution of
distributed or on a partitioning
algorithm and then move the graph what
we do is we build hashing function that
encodes the appropriate distribution
essentially often we use a perfect
hashing function based on a known static
distribution that'll also give you
information about distribution of
incoming vertices if things become
unbalanced of course you need to
recompute your hashing function to do
something better the idea is by using
hashing function it usually takes much
less memory and less computation to tell
where things are going to go and you can
evolve in memory it may not be the
evolution but it's usually workable
illusory yes in your library are in the
boost graphic library to build brass
dynamically
yes
sure
one of the first slice of your
presentation you talked about in later
sessions that point did the virtual
functions and housing back performace
negatively and all that sure and but but
it seemed that you were presenting your
your approach as some form a way to
address that problem and I don't know
it's just the way I see it is there
they're kind of different problems at
different types of abstraction one is
more rent runtime the other one is more
compile-time way you have the
opportunity to do static and ice of
course you're going to get sure better
optimization opportunities there the
static everything is statically so as I
know if you intend to propose as or to
present as a solution to that wrong or
you make that distinction so the the
distinction you make is that with
object-oriented programming I shouldn't
say all but nearly all object-oriented
languages out there tie the notion of
runtime poly type polymorphism to
runtime polymorphism we don't like to
make that distinction we like to look at
just polymorphism and in the languages
that we typically use like C++ we use
the polymorphic mechanisms that evaluate
it at compile time and therefore give
you better performance now there's
nothing that prevents those same
mechanisms from being implemented at
runtime now you've seen this well with
the c-sharp in the.net virtual machine
with the generics can be executed at
runtime they can also be instantiated
runtime they could be instantiated
earlier if need be so I think one of the
things we're looking at is with
functions in object-oriented programming
runtime polymorphism run time has come
with the polymorphism we'd really like
to and make the dis compile time
decision something that's programmer
controlled or compiled by or controlled
by optimizers is supposed to being
fundamental in the ideas
for problems problems with the C++
language and supercilious components so
there are there are languages with
stronger type systems that give the
compiler more information about what's
going on sure there are I mean in
programming language research they're
well known techniques to be able to do
type analysis data flow analysis and
figure about for example if for a
specific column vacation is only one
type a specific type could ever flow
their short any kin to the optimization
other I think their religious wars
fought over this thing to be said one
thing to be said for the other side is
that compiler does have an easier time
of avoiding code bloat so for example
sometimes actually don't want to
instantiate instantiate specifically
image type term times if you can
determine that this is actually not
going to be the inner loop especially if
you're doing kind of runtime
optimization as you're going sometimes
it's actually more efficient to step one
copy the code that maybe has more
instructions but it's more likely to say
in the instruction cache
right well that would be another reason
to tease apart the notion of
polymorphism from the notion of what is
it run timer is it compile time and most
languages don't give you that choice c++
also doesn't give you that choice except
manually you can you can convert a
template into something that is more
dynamically dispatch you want regarding
compiler optimizations there are
optimizations that candy virtualize
functions and it's it's hard in C++ and
the concern is that when you when you're
building up many fractions you're
building a deep abstractions because you
know you're mapping through domains etc
what at some point you overload the
compilers ability regardless of how
smart the compiler is you're going to
overload stability and then you get this
drop-off wear your performance is fine
and then it tanks yes you don't
functions stop working with this maybe
you start doing some specializations
that cocalo just goes out with exactly
exactly but think the answer is to
really tease this out it it's not an
issue of it's an issue that really needs
programmer control and that's probably
all worked for the Holy Grail over the
whole thing is unified and we find the
exactly there are trade off to give the
compiler the information to make the
right decision without the that's
possible part of is finding a way to
express polymorphism in a way that's
amenable to both static optimization and
dynamic compilation and I don't don't
know that we have that yet get into the
world of parametric polymorphism that's
seems like the right place to be because
you can do substitution templates
certainly aren't the right answer
because you can't compile those yeah we
need something new
I was wondering during your presentation
it seems that you tested all these
algorithms with one type of cluster
which seems a homogeneous cluster with
message passing paradigm to know how
much you explore extending your approach
to other types with heterogeneous
clusters or shared memory or whatever
we've done a little exploration into the
world of more into shared memory and
threads seeing how the abstractions
holed up in that place and what we found
is that of course you can treat threads
like a message passing system if you
want but it's not the most efficient way
to do things so what we found is that
what you want to do is at the very top
level treat do treat threads like a
message passing system and you build a
process group that's threading it does
all of its communication through shared
memory etc it's still doing message
passing then the next step is you start
specializing the parts of the library
where you can get big performance
improvements so for example if you have
one of these property maps where you
have information about all the various
some attribute for all the vertical
vertices in the graph now a distributed
property map is really expensive it has
ghost cells it does communication over
these go cells in shared memory of
course you could just lay out the entire
thing in one big shared memory segment
and now start using box or atomic
operations and so the way we deal with
this is not to build new algorithms it's
to provide a specialized version of the
distributed property map data structure
that only applies to these threaded
process groups where things live in
shared memory and then you're putting
your get operations now map down to
atomic so now a map down is something
with locks but the rest of the algorithm
still does its message passing it still
uses the idea of process groups so the
idea is you can very quickly move from
one communication medium to another and
then only specialize the parts where
performance really matters
how does that work when you have a
cluster of machines where you have two
should be processing at the cluster
level right but you have good Carlo
pressing with multiple processors check
for each individual machine actually two
different approaches we would need two
levels for that yeah which we have not
done this the the view point is that we
would build essentially a composed
process group that knows what our local
process numbers and what aren't local
process numbers and do the local
optimizations with Atomics within one
compute node and fall back to message
passing there's certainly going to be
some overhead and making the decision of
which to do there but it's going to be
much better than the overhead of
including extra go cells etc etc
extraction building a my very business
afford that that's what you say it does
not support that case she said too many
mess too much welcome adversities around
so because these you have different
dispute is to find graduating of the so
we do batch messages the the process
group of abstraction is actually a big
level step above NPI and the process
well we have an MPI process group for
instance we do batch together messages
been associated do somehow internal
report concluded a better together then
yes yes so the view from the programmer
side writing at algorithm using this is
that you have fine grain messages but
the actual implementation is going to
batch messages as appropriate for the
network's bandwidth and latency
characteristics in some cases you do
need the semantics of this has to go out
now because I need to wait for a reply
and there's a special channel it's
called out a band messaging that will go
over quickly it should only be used
sparingly and in fact in library we only
use it when the user has done something
that requires an immediate answer will
never do it internally on
roan because it's not efficient yes
sometimes they get for synchronization
so can you comment on like all the
number do you have a couple of graphs
that showed performance improvements and
I can imagine that when you build the
SDK or when you build the application
you start with it but with google for
correctness you go give the least
specialized version something that
already works on 10 other different data
structures right and once you have your
data structures plugged in there and
they are sort of saying then you get
some correct answer first yes then you
move so in the grass important question
is how much effort does it take to go
from the first car which you're not too
proud of to the last one where you're
like okay I've done enough I've got
enough speed up and then it's time to
make that slide and put it out there how
much is there and is it is your only
trick that specialization or is it how
do you go about tuning like a like pv GL
that's template-based for so how long
does it take very so much from algorithm
to algorithm so some things that the
Delta steppin out with my showed we
actually we did this because we want to
compare against one of korea's exotic
architectures and it took a day to
implement in parallel vgl and a data to
knit and then we've been using those
numbers since then we we use there's
usually two tricks that go into
optimizing first is algorithmic
optimizations the first thing you do
because they're the most generic and
they work across a wide variety of
platforms and then the second step is we
start specializing down for four maybe
it's the architecture maybe it's a
particular data structure whatever and
so we'll add those specializations in
and usually in the worst case this is
sort of a process that comes from both
ends we're doing algorithmic
optimizations up here and sometimes you
just have to build a quick and dirty
prototype that has no templates in it is
not generic to see how well can I
actually do on my data structures and
then you convert those into two
specializations and lift those
specializations up to the point where it
gives you the performance benefit and
the
University possible so we see it as sort
of a build the generic first and then
integrate other ideas from concrete
Optima from concrete implementations at
the appropriate level to get the right
optimizations and we can accrue these
things many of them over time frame work
just gives you a good initial vision
point but there's still work that
usually expected through specialization
or trying to change the algorithm itself
yeah there's always working
specialization and the way generic
libraries usually evolve is you have the
most generic version and then as you
find new ideas that only work at
specific points you drop them into the
right part and you end up with a really
a hierarchy of algorithms that all have
the same name and there's just a
dispatching process that picks the best
one based on the properties of the data
structure is using at that particular
point in time
well thank you